uh i just want to start with i've seen
all of mcgruber and i've seen a few
episodes of 1883
and uh it's just been great to enjoy
your work uh especially just i just want
to say congrats on both series um i am
curious you've done so many awesome
roles if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
wow
that's something i've never thought of
i guess it depends on how much they're
going to watch
you know
if that makes any sense
if they want to watch it all then they
ought to start in the beginning
when i played a role in a movie called a
way west the role of an extra
when i went to college up in
oregon at the u of o i
worked on this show called the way west
and it was actually about this a journey
on the oregon trail
that was my first job in a movie
business
i was i was
kind of soft in the background and
walking behind this wagon that sally
field was
that was a long time ago i don't know
you know
i've got favorite pieces
maybe star wars born maybe conor which
is a louis lamar thing that i did with
my wife a long time ago
you know there are there's a number of
them are special and there's a number of
them that are completely forgetful
you know
some that you know
certainly today i wish i'd never done
maybe on some level but
that said i
i shouldn't even have said that i don't
think there's anything that i wish i
hadn't done
i think that there's some work that i'm
certainly not so proud of that early on
but
it's all kind of a continuum you know
in the early days i would have done
anything to work
because it's you know it's like going to
school
it wasn't about the money it was about
doing the work and i
i discovered early on and
made a very conscious decision
not to do everything that came my way
forever
i wasn't motivated by money and it
wasn't in the business to make money
so
when i decided that i i
i had the ability to be selective about
what kind of stuff i did and if if the
material wasn't there then i didn't see
any point in getting involved in it
i think as soon as you start working for
money and you just do a job because it's
there that that's when people get tired
of looking at you
so i don't know
not much good answer for your question
but
no i actually think i think it's a very
good answer actually and it says uh but
i agree at the beginning of your career
you're going to take anything you can
get because it's the experience of what
me it's what
made you who you are today yeah and it
leads you know work work leads to work
work gets work you know one of the
things watching the series is that it's
it's not a soundstage show this is all
on location and i i have to imagine this
was an incredibly challenging shoot can
you sort of talk about the like the
behind the scenes of making this series
yeah it still is we're still at it we're
still in production and we'll be like
mid-january even though we're going to
start streaming
in another week or 10 days whenever the
19th comes up which is even hard to
wrap your head around in some ways
it's been it's been very difficult i
know when taylor
first gave me this opportunity
he told me you're going to [ __ ] hate
me by the end of this thing and he was
talking about the journey the conditions
the what it was going to be like making
a film
i'm certainly not going to hate him
because of it but it's definitely what
he promised you know we started out
outside of fort worth texas and
the end of august working in 100 and 708
degree weather
everybody's wearing wool clothes
you know it was brutal and you know
we're in the sun and there's no getting
out of it
we did that for six or seven weeks and
we went up to montana and worked in you
know surrounded by snow-capped mountains
and you know
weather in the teens you know with a
chip with a chill factor
so it's been an interesting we got blown
off the set over in amarillo the other
day with in a dust storm that just shut
the company down
you know so it's it's
it's been difficult it hasn't been an
easy shoot it hadn't been an easy shoot
for the cast or the crew
probably harder on the crew and the
horses and everybody else than it has
been for us
you know
but
i think what matters is
what's on the screen in the end and
they're getting beautiful stuff they're
really getting beautiful stuff and i'm
proud to be part of it
great i already got a stop
i was gonna say i already have to stop
i'm just gonna say it looks fantastic on
the screen it
looks like you guys are putting in the
time and energy to make something
special i know it'll be a hit
thank you for your time thank you for
yours appreciate it
you